I want you to react to this statement by
uh past guest on the show Albert
Einstein
Einstein said the following about two
different dynamics of of human
capability he called the and this is
from a book called The the metaphoric
Mind by Bob samples he said Albert
Einstein called the intuitive or
metaphoric mind a sacred gift he added
that the rational mind was a faithful
servant
it is a paradoxical it is paradoxical
that in the context of Modern Life we
have begun to worship the servant and to
defile the Divine oh I love it so what
do you see it possible to have both
signs the intuitive metaphoric the
sacred gift the Divine and that rational
sorry go ahead he had both I mean this
is this is the interesting thing right
which is the
what was it inspiration is more
important than knowledge imagination
imagine like the center for human
imagination
right
um
the rational people are oh you know uh
with great spirits have always
encountered uh violent opposition for
mediocre Minds
in order to make huge advances you have
to be wrong in the process
and what you find is you try to imagine
uh E.E Cummings turning in a poem
and a copy editor saying the
capitalization is off the punctuation is
wrong the grammar is non-existent yeah
no kidding it's EE Cummings
um great minds have to be able to do
things that are wrong
when to rock you know came up with his
equation he had numbers where a times B
wasn't B times a
and it wasn't until he realized that
they were matrices that he could make
sense of what he'd written if you can't
go through wrong you can't Advance all
right and thought the positron was the
proton right that's true
um and Galileo thought the tides were
caused by the orbit of the earth not the
moon so in all of these situations
um
you've got this sort of copy editing
group that's always angry because it
never wins the answer stop being a copy
editor you have to is that why you think
gu is experiencing get has experienced
you know kind of passions and opposition
or do you think it's people realize what
are you saying about that I haven't had
almost any gu conversations the question
that you're trying to ask me is
something like what's been the reaction
to gu and what I'm telling you is it's
not what you're saying
the reaction is I've lectured in two
places because of covid uh one in in
Marseille in France and the other
University of Chicago at the cadenoff
center I've had perfectly polite
conversations people are interested in
various aspects but the the academic
um
incentive structure
the ability to be viable means that
you've got to Ally yourself with people
who can fund you and who can hire you
and who can give you tenure and
everyone's worried about their
reputation and nobody's worried about
physics
when I say nobody I don't mean
absolutely nobody I had a great
conversation with for example Nima
arkani Hamed recently it's just gonna
say you you're right what was his
reaction then I mean was he willing to
engage it or was it polite of course you
know he's very constructive you know his
point is I I learned a great deal from
Nema
um and Nema isn't like
I mean let me just say it
Nema in my estimation
is the soul of theoretical physics right
now
because he has an ability to do
something that I think almost no one
else does which is dead reckoning
he we've lost sort of the the compass
heading from experiment because the
energy levels have gotten prohibitive
for new for new phenomena we failed for
a great deal of time so most people are
demoralized
theoretical physics lives even when Nema
and I disagree or he says something
that's critical of me
that's what real critique is what he
told me to do is hey here are the sorts
of things that you can grab the
attention of the quantum field Theory
Community now I learned something very
very important which I would love to
discuss on the show
um
I think one of the big problems is that
there are these three legs to the
mathematical stool which is geometry
algebra and Analysis I.E calculus
the problem with Quantum field theory is
that it grew up unbalanced it's really
almost all analysis and then we found
out very late in the day that we'd been
neglecting certain topological geometric
and algebraic things and sort of
starting in the 70s with Jim Simons for
the last 50 years
um people like Ed Whitton Graham Siegel
Dan Quillen uh Luis alvarez-game have
been
um making Quantum field Theory geometric
and that's been the basic Vector of
success in the field
but what would you come to understand is
that analysis is too brutal and crude of
a tool to have this responsibility for
carrying physics forward and I'll give
this a simple example
if you have a function like a little
lump of probability that represents
where a particle can be and then you try
to propagate that function how do you
know that the propagation of that
function isn't going to turn the
function negative in some places or how
do you know that the function as a lump
isn't going to start moving faster than
light and screw up causality or how do
you know that the integral of the
probability under that function is going
to remain 1.00
so none of those things are really
natural inside of analysis but it seems
like the geometry and the
um deeper algebraic principles ensure
that all of those things are true
and this goes back to something that you
know Esther perel once said to me the
great relationship uh coach and
therapist and she said the thing about
masculinity is that it's incredibly
powerful and just as fragile
in other words
a masculine male is an incredibly
powerful person who can be damaged
um
by a single straight comment uh you know
from a woman and and cut low and cut to
the quick
that situation is true in Quantum field
Theory which is it's incredibly powerful
but it is just as fragile
[Music]